here's the G7 a group of seven of the
world's advanced economies including the
US UK and Japan and here's what some
call the alternative from the developing
world the bricks formed by Brazil Russia
India China and South Africa the brics
is trying to position itself as the
voice for emerging economies and
challenge Western dominance of global
Affairs its leaders are holding a summit
in Johannesburg to discuss an historic
expansion more than 40 countries
including Saudi Arabia and Iran want to
join the expansion of bricks could
definitely boost the group's Global
influence let's look at what a potential
enlargement means for the alliance and
its Ambitions to shake up the global
political and economic order
the original term brick was actually
coined by a Goldman Sachs Banker
grouping these really different
countries together because they were so
fast growing the leaders of Brazil
Russia India and China formalized their
relationship in 2009 and invited South
Africa to join the alliance a year later
they decided to take that idea in an
effort to create a bit of a political
and economic Counterpoint to what's
perceived as Western hegemony of the
global political and economic spheres
the brics countries together make up
more than 40 percent of the world's
population and almost a third of the
world's GDP
according to data from the international
monetary fund the block has already
overtaken the G7 nation's share of the
global economy on the basis of
purchasing power parity that's where the
purchasing power of different currencies
is equalized projections by Goldman
Sachs showed the world's economic
balance shifting towards the bricks and
emerging economies China is expected to
overtake the us as the world's largest
economy by 2050 with India climbing to
number three China and India have
experienced massive growth since the
bricks were founded in 2009 and
certainly have helped them swell in
importance and remain relevant on the
global stage
China and Russia are pushing to enlarge
bricks experts say Beijing is Keen to
create an alternative grouping to
counter the US and the West on the world
stage
China has been bullish on expanding
brics for some time and they're
particularly Keen at the moment because
of the trade tensions with the US the US
looking to diversify its Supply chains
away from China Russia sees an expansion
as a way to gain more International
allies following its full-scale invasion
of Ukraine
foreign
South Africa publicly supports the
expansion Estus Brazil but experts say
behind the scenes Brazil and India wants
a more measured approach it seems that
they are concerned about the group
leaning to autocratic so they want to
have very specific requirements for
admission to make sure that there's a
balance amongst the members and that it
doesn't become sort of the autocratic G7
more than 20 countries have formally
applied to become part of brics ranging
from Saudi Arabia to Ethiopia Argentina
and Indonesia experts say Saudi Arabia
is a strong candidate as a major
economic and energy power in the Middle
East with a growing role in Regional
diplomacy Indonesia with world's fourth
largest population is another strong
Contender Indonesia being such a large
economy and important in the
electrification clean energy Tech
electric vehicles might be a logical
Choice one reason for joining the bricks
is gaining access to the Block's new
development Bank
since its founding in 2014 the bank has
approved more than 30 billion dollars in
loans for development and infrastructure
projects access to funding from this
bank which seemed to be having more
favorable terms than a traditional
Development Bank like the World Bank or
the IMF is definitely something that's
attractive to a lot of countries the new
development Bank also wants to deepen
the use of local currencies instead of
the US dollar for trade and financing
between the brics Nations
ultimately experts say one of the
biggest challenges for the brics to
counter the West is to form a United
voice on major Global issues generally
the countries have pretty diverse and
diverging interests in politics in on
security issues and even relations with
the US I think the group would like to
be seen as an alternative political
Forum to the G7 group of developed
Nations whether or not it is able to
achieve that I think will largely depend
on what countries it admits
thank you